bonsoir nadège le gouvernement qui est
droit dans ses bottes
manifestement qui dit mercredi 10
nouveau conseil de défense sur les
crises sanitaires suivi lui-même d'un
conseil des ministres
absolument et gabriela talent a tenu une
conférence de presse à l'issue de ces
rendez-vous le porte parole du
gouvernement elle dit et qu'il existe un
chemin pour éviter leur confinement
les chiffres apparaissent déclinants
depuis ces dernières semaines at il
ajouté alors que rappelez vous il ya une
dizaine de jours elle à l'hypothèse
d'une d'un troisième confinement se
voulaient de plus en plus insistantes
gabriella talent lui même le porte
parole du gouvernement et bien avait lui
même parlé d'un confinement serré
aujourd'hui laden vous l'aurez compris a
quelque peu changé
il existe bien un chemin pour éviter
leur confinement ce chemin n'est pas
large mais il existe et nous aurions
tort de ne pas tout mettre en oeuvre
pour y parvenir nous sommes toujours sur
le même plateau au même si il apparaît
légèrement déclinant depuis une semaine
il faut évidemment rester extrêmement
prudent la situation reste fragile
il y a par ailleurs des disparités
territoriales face à cette situation
globale et nadège dans le même temps des
scientifiques s'inquiètent d'une poussée
du variant britannique
absolument c'est le cas par exemple du
chef du service des maladies
infectieuses hôpital tenon à paris elle
lui est bien est favorable à un
renforcement des restrictions sanitaires
et un confinement
on observe une poussée incroyable du
variant anglais on nous a dit ce n'est
pas autant que l'angleterre mais l'île
de france est autour de 30 9% de
nouvelles contaminations
on va dans le mur d'un point de vue
strictement sanitaires on ne voit pas
comment on peut échapper un confinement
et l'autre information du journal belge
c'est celle ci locaux vides 19 aurait
été présent en france dès l'automne 2010
c'est en tout cas ce qu'affirme une
équipe de chercheurs français de
l'institut national de la santé et de la
recherche médicale pour aboutir à cette
conclusion ils ont analysé plus de neuf
mille échantillons sanguins collectées
sur les deux cent mille participants
d'une vaste étude épidémiologique sur le
couronnais virus mais ces résultats
suggèrent que dès les mois de novembre
et décembre le taux de contamination
dans la population française est déjà de
l'ordre d'un cas pour mille on semble
trouver des cas de manière sporadique un
peu partout sur le territoire
dans plus de la moitié des cas on a
affaire à des gens qui ont voyagé ou qui
ont été en contact avec des personnes
ayant été malades
l'un des caves et voyager 2 mois en asie
et est revenu début décembre en france
des conclusions qui met à mal
l'hypothèse d'un départ de l'épidémie au
début du mois de décembre 2019 depuis un
marché de hoàn en chine une tête ce qui
va dans le sens de l'équipe d'experts
chinois et de l'organisation mondiale de
la santé oms qui juge par ailleurs
hautement improbable la fuite du virus
d'un laboratoire et privilégient la
piste d'un animal intermédiaire
l'origine de la transmission animal qui
pour l'heure n'a pas encore été
identifié merci nadège à dera sach en
direct donc de l'elysée